In Indonesia, disaster officials say 29 people...
...died and dozens more are missing...
...after a ferry ran aground off the island of Sulawesi.
In Poland, Supreme Court First President Malgorzata Gersdorf...
...showed up for work, defying a new law forcing her retirement.
In Thailand, rescuers are racing against time...
...to get a youth soccer team out of the partially flooded cave...
...where they have been trapped for more than a week...
...as forecasters predict heavy rains in the coming days.
In Malaysia, former Prime Minister Najib Razak...
...is claiming his innocence after being charged...
...with a criminal breach of trust and corruption...
...in a Kuala Lumpur court on Wednesday.
And finally from the United States, the Trump administration...
...is allowing Chinese telecommunications giant ZTE...
...to carry on some business in the United States...
...as it works to resume full operations...
...after US sanctions nearly shut it down.